hello my name is alvin hello
and today i will be showing you my
recipe for chicken parmesan
that was a lot of words
hello my name is alvin and today i will
be showing you my recipe for chicken
parmesan stuffed garlic bread
so this is definitely one of my more
crazier tasty recipes i sat on this
concept for like six months i'm not even
kidding i really want to combine garlic
bread with something else because
everybody likes garlic bread and garlic
bread should not be only a side dish it
deserves to be the main attraction i
want to combine it with something that's
like an entree so i was like oh what do
you eat garlic bread with uh meatballs
spaghetti pasta chicken parm oh chicken
parm sounds really good it's got
everything that garlic bread needs in a
best friend i was like i need to find a
way to make chicken parmesan mixed in
with garlic bread so my idea was that
instead of doing a whole chicken breast
i would cut chicken breast up into
smaller strips bread them fry them
separately so you almost have like these
little chicken tenders that you can work
with
[Music]
after that i would wrap each chicken
tender with a slice of mozzarella cheese
because that's what chicken parm needs
and then i would take this little like
chicken cheese cylindrical thingy and
put it inside a hollowed out baguette i
think that you need to make sure that
you get a baguette that is not too thin
because you're going to hollow it out
because you're going to hollow out the
baguette you need to make sure that you
take a really thin sharp knife and cut
out like the filling of the bread we
don't want to waste that you can use
that for croutons you know sometimes the
middle of the bread can be the best part
i ate way too much of it as a kid so
don't throw that away but just make sure
that you hollow out a big enough hole
that your fried chicken with the cheese
around it can fit in and i would cut
that into small pieces try to make sure
that when you cut your chicken it's
uniform all the way through because if
you start with a piece that's like too
wide at one end and too narrow the other
you might get like halfway into the
bread and then it's going to be like
nope i don't want to go in anymore and
then we'll stop once you perfectly fit
the chicken and the cheese inside the
baguette you want to make sure that you
line it all up cut them into about an
inch pieces because this is meant to be
hand-held food once you cut them up line
it on the tray brush some amazing garlic
butter that you make over the top which
is super super easy just some garlic
just some butter maybe some parsley if
you want for color be liberal you know
garlic bread whoever's eating it i don't
think they're trying to be on a diet so
and you don't and you also don't have to
tell them how much you put in it so
brush liberally it'll get absorbed it'll
be delicious nobody's gonna complain
everybody loves garlic breads after you
brush it with butter cover it with foil
or don't depending on how crispy you
want your garlic bread to bake it off
and you have this wonderful wonderful
finger food for your party what's great
about it is because you've made these
cuts and because you put them back
together in the oven the cheese is
actually going to help it all stick
together so when it comes to the table
and people pull it apart you get that
amazing signature tasty cheese pull that
i've spent way too long trying to get
sometimes i think you serve it with a
side of marinara sauce you have all the
elements of chicken parmesan and garlic
bread in one single bite which i think
is really really cool because it's a
handheld version of a usual dish that
requires a fork and a knife so i think
this is a great idea i wasn't sure if it
was gonna be too much work where
everybody was gonna be like this is
stupid like why would you ever do this
but eventually one day i was like you
know what alvin if you're not going to
make this idea you'll probably go mad so
i buckled down i cooked the recipe i
edited the video and it actually turned
out to be
really really cool if you have a party
coming up and you want to make this dish
feel free to customize it however you
like if you end up making it let me know
post in the comments i want to see a
picture because i love when people make
my recipes so feel free to do it for any
party i will guarantee it's a crowd
pleaser so happy cooking
[Music]
you